Let's go next to our caller from the nine,
seven, eight area code.
Who's calling today from 970?
Hi, can you hear me?
Yes, I can't.
Who's this?
My name is Mark.
I live in Framingham.
All right.
And Mark, please just keep the phone.
You're coming in.
Shot out of a cannon.
Very, very hot.
Just try to either talk a little more quietly
or maybe keep that the mouthpiece a little
further from your mouth.
OK.
In some sense.
All right.
Well, first, I'd like to know what do you
think makes Trump an anomaly?
Because you've said that you think Trump is
just uniquely bad, considering that Bush invaded
nations that were still in after decades against
international law, even though the U.N. said
there were weapons of mass destruction.
How was Trump any more of a corrupt evil gangster
than Bush was?
That's my first question.
So first, we have a sort of category error,
which is you are it sounds like you're saying
let's supply the sort of foreign policy standards
that we would applied to typical neo cons
to Donald Trump in order to evaluate them
against each other.
And what I would assert is that we're dealing
with category differences.
Donald Trump is bad in a way that is very
different than how George W. Bush was bad.
And of course, if you're looking for someone
to defend George W. Bush, that's certainly
not going to be me.
We spent, you know, the greater part of Bush's
presidency pointing out all of the ways in
which Bush was bad.
Got Donald Trump is bad in a different way.
And I'll give you one example that I think
is relevant.
George W. Bush's foreign policy is the disgusting
neo con foreign policy of people like John
Bolton.
And, you know, Wolf, full Witz and Rumsfeld
and so on and so forth.
And that's absolutely horrible.
But George W. Bush would not have screwed
up Corona virus the way Donald Trump did.
And this is not praise of Bush and Bush.
It was a disaster on Katrina, mostly for different
reasons.
But even someone as uniquely horrible as Bush
from the foreign policy perspective would
not have mess this up in the way that Donald
Trump did.
George W. Bush made the wrong foreign policy
decisions with Iraq, but he didn't ruin so
many of our longstanding alliances and get
the United States to be essentially ignored
in large swaths of the global decisions that
have to be made.
So I just think that there's a category difference.
The ways in which I criticize Bush are different
fundamentally than the ways in which Trump
has been an embarrassing failure.
All right.
Well, well, but what if.
But don't you think that also the NSA and
Peter and the Patriot Act by Bush were also
things that were also evil examples of domestic
policy as well?
Yes, but both of those contained horrible
provisions.
Yes, I agree with that.
OK.
And my last question, which is just a total
irrelevant to the first two.
I know you're a big chess player.
If someone were trying to get into chess,
what resources do you think would be best
for a beginner?
I would just go on YouTube and just Google
chess for beginners, and you'll find hundreds
of hours of simple videos just getting people
introduced to the concepts and then also lead
chess dot org slash practice has a bunch of
free resources for just starting to learn
the basics.
OK, thank you, David.
I really enjoyed it.
All right, great.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much